[Applause]
this is not good this is not good guys
at all we're in like Stage five full
armed crisis mode right now are you
aware of what a snafu is it's time to
make Boston door sorry boss
town dynamics to we're gonna we're gonna
figure out how we're actually gonna make
this Boston Dynamics is being funded by
DARPA so it's no secret these these
aren't necessarily just innocent walking
robots like there is eventually this
purpose fear these robots to be
combatants in the military what is the
like the military testing version of
Boston Dynamics look like they're
probably doing this they're probably
messing with this stuff
I mean how what Boston Dynamics doesn't
want the biggest take away I think
people got through the first one was the
emotional connection to this robot that
is getting beat people just don't like
seeing that at the same time it's kind
of a big source of our comedy here is
this ridiculous level of bullying it
definitely takes it up to the next level
yeah yeah and in every way so here we
are
[Music]
they release there's so many great
little things that we can partner these
perfect last time we shot Boston
Dynamics it was in the studio in a
controlled environment with good
internet now this next one it's gonna be
on a private gun range we won't have
internet we'll have to bring our own
generators for power so right now I'm
tasked with creating a mobile field
mocap setup and we can't film this video
unless I figure that out the technology
it's working ok the ultimate test we're
going outside
[Music]
yeah it's on exploding
any minute now
careful careful looks like some kind of
ritual
not working why isn't it working man
this isn't working not gonna be able to
make this video right now
it's really working I have to count okay
I have you calibrated online
here we go here we go here we go here we
go he do a little jig
yeah it's working guys now we can film
Boston Dynamics too
[Music]
everything a pocket full of shells
two or three times bucket one of those
bucket
[Music]
[Laughter]
so everyone's out at the boss town to
shoot I'm just following along on social
media to check in on their status looks
like everything went smooth though I'm
kind of jealous of their ride right now
yeah I'm glad it went well
this is not good it's not good boys just
not good can show you real quick to show
you something yeah tell me this
we filmed Boston Dynamics - he's gonna
full day out in the desert getting beat
getting dirt kicked up my nose take a
look at these files right these are the
motion capture files 0 and 507 so
there's this giant gap we just spent the
last hour trying to figure out where
that motion capture footage went and I
think we have concluded that it is gone
and missing but it's not like missing to
be found it's disappeared it's yeah it's
gone not coming back basically how it
works is that we roll on the camera the
red camera are using and then we also
roll on the motion capture so that later
we could syncing up that's the entire
idea behind the shoot but we think what
was happening is that every time they
were saving the motion capture data
it was receiving over a previous file
over and over and over again for four
and a half hours can we just redo the
motion capture here in the studio and
the short answer is no again it's like
the footage in the motion capture data
have to go hand-in-hand so you're
telling me all of this comes down to
hitting save rather than save as it's
the only thing that legitimately makes
us our best theory as a hell of a puzzle
they don't want to start pointing
fingers but I'm just gonna throw out a
few suggestions there's some people that
have dealt with this data so let's look
at he dealt with the data
Sam Gorski was responsible for
overseeing the data transfer he started
it and left and didn't stick around to
verify whether or not it got done until
the next day yes I see your point
Peter friends lovely guy you've seen it
you've all seen him also
problem with data peter was responsible
for capturing the motion capture that
was his job for the day it's happened in
the past he lost an entire day of
footage now I'm not saying it was
Colonel Mustard in the billiards room
with the candlestick that's probably it
this bad man and we will need to go and
reshoot four giant sequences of events
that require us to film and then to
mocap and it's going to take another
full day
anytime we hit like these crazy heart
roadblocks I just I find myself having
to come up here to the roof to just kind
of like think
about our patrons who support us on
patreon come just saying their names
gives me the willpower to continue
because without them we wouldn't be able
to make the stuff that we do Bailey
Wilson Dave crooks Harris read sip a
jack
Oscar bunting Philip Oxford Ellen and
Almanza nota canned dad
Ian's spy college cube skin key snack
who is that Brian and toesik as well as
all of our other patrons thank you you
know what I think that works I feel much
better now
let's I'm ready to tackle this let's go
[Music]
we got back out there we reshot day two
it was like half the shots in the whole
short footage looks really nice so
that's good but now we're behind
schedule we're really behind and before
we can hop in the post I gotta get this
robot up and runnin the boss town one
you know you got your standard bot it's
not that special there's really not that
special a lot has changed since boss
town one our boss town boy grew up drew
some armor
welcome to the new and improved Boston
Dynamics robot this is a military robot
for testing weapons out in the desert
this guy is souped up and ready for
battle different color scheme you know
we're going military armor plating if
you look closely there's a little hole
in its chest there like it got hit with
like a crowbar maybe a bullet we have a
codpiece look at this thing one
completely different leg pieces here we
got our logo back here corridor digital
logo oh yeah
I got like Kenda straps around the back
of the robot to hold it in place but BAM
look at these Pitman hands this is
actually taken from the Boston Dynamics
robot called pet man and they actually
designed it to wear military clothing
and go out into areas to test the
clothing and then he has the sensor
piece right here that actually swivels
around I think it looks awesome I'm very
excited to see this thing in motion this
little guy this is a 3d model of the
real spot dog this is an actual real
thing Boston Dynamics actually is gonna
be selling this thing they just dropped
a spot release trailer and that's great
for me because I'm gonna watch that over
and over and over and animate this dog
to match the actual movement of the real
spot in that release trailer he comes in
at the end hopefully you guys watch to
the end don't you guys watch the video
go watch the video it's it's great it
should be up right now it might be a lie
I don't know it should be up so I've got
the dog I've got the military boss town
robot connected to the mocap data so now
I'm going to show the guys so there's a
dog under there like a robot dog and
they they want me to shoot it you can't
ever shoot a dog man I mean the minute I
ever see a movie where somebody shoots a
dog or hurts a dog that's it
whoever shot the dog has got to die no
normal human being out there would ever
want to see a dog mistreated ever I
personally think the relationship
between man and dog is like a real tight
one and a real old one they're gonna
love you no matter what you go down you
go hit the mail you walk back up you
just saw him 30 seconds to go
around they want to be you know they
want to go do something with you it's
like their whole job is they want to
please you and get fed while he's like
aiming his gun at it in deciding what
he's gonna do I can do two things I can
either have the the robot dog be like
kind of injured and like sad and crying
or it's happy and it's so excited to see
his robot friend and he's like licking
the gun and he's like thinks it's
playing if I came up to my dog and I had
a gun and I was pointing the gun at it
my dog would still be happy because it
wouldn't believe that I was about ready
to kill her it's even more sad it's like
the end of mice and men they're gonna be
going off on a new adventure he has
saved the dog he's not willing to have
her going into hiding you do a third one
yeah where he's in this cabin and he's
like scavenging for nuts and bolts and
oil and like he's trying to like feed
his dog and he doesn't have enough food
for himself and you have all these
scientists coming out like looking for
the robot so the robots been rendered
out and it's looking really really nice
so basically now we're in the process we
need to make sure it is blended in and
it looks right there's a lot of
rotoscoping to be done here a ton of
rotoscoping we have to like track in all
of the actual gun plates that we film
because we actually brought live
firearms on set but the biggest most
difficult part of this whole process is
painting me out for every single one of
these shots yeah it's a painstaking
process
[Music]
[Applause]
the creative team has overextended
themselves trying to do too much in a
video it's October 22nd we've been
working on this video since the
beginning of June there's this weird
glitch going on that we can't seem to
explain basically the footage is cursed
I've been working off of cursed footage
for this whole thing everything goes
back in references the cursed book so
usually when we work on a corridor video
we try to keep it contained three weeks
four weeks maximum its first Boston
Dynamics this guy spent like three or
four weeks on it and it's kind of
stressful what they got it done so here
we are going on to week seven Oh boss
town - you know from a time but -
standpoint all these other things are
happening in corridor that aren't this
video put things in a tough spot this is
the last week it has to be done by a
Saturday it cannot go beyond this
Saturday this is definitely problem in
after-effects and in all editing
programs really there's this idea called
nesting or pre composing so you got your
footage thing this your footage you got
your robot bang and you got your
rotoscoping thing these are three
different layers put them together
inside of a folder now this folder is
considered a single file again so now I
can take this and I can draw on it and
it will effect all three of these layers
within it's the same way the problem
that we're facing is that we're seeing
this really intense glitch I'm looking
at a certain friend here but anytime I
go inside of this these frames have been
shifted to the left by one frame so it's
like oh why don't you just shift the
frame forward well when you do that it
has a ripple effect through all the
other pre comps now the roto layers are
referencing the wrong frame that
shouldn't happen these it this seems
like the simplest of problems and yet
somehow we're not able to solve it yes
this is super bizarre
yes we've done that that was the second
thing we did what I don't think it will
fix it personally I mean that seems to
work
why is to clean blade off now it was the
last Boston Dynamics video we started
with cool high tech beeps and Boop's
first and then get fully kind of towards
the end this time I'm taking a different
approach
I'm starting with Bowie from square one
that way we have a nice rich pass of
audio for this one I'm using a battery
operated drill for the legs I'm using an
electric skateboard for the hips and
general movement any of that that stuff
it's kind of deeper and bass here and so
it's good for the full body I'm using RC
car steering wheels for like hands and
fine detail stuff those tiny squeaks up
top this is what the gun sounds are like
without any processing oh wow Sam are
you telling me that's what gun sounds
are like before you work your magic on
them yeah now the magic happens here go
magic
[Applause]
I was like I took my my uh my tube and I
took that this thin skinny piece of
audio I was like and blew up into this
big rich sound even though both myself
Clint Sam and Mika all four of us with
our powers combined couldn't even
individually troubleshoot what the
problem was it wasn't the fray right
thing it was an interpreter footage
thing whatever was we ended up having to
brute force our way through it which was
just a lot of work but Clint had to go
through and render out every single
layer as his own individual piece of
footage and re-import that into a brand
new project file looks like these boys
are on track I mean do I dare say that
and go too far no matter what that video
goes up tomorrow also it's going to have
to I finished whatever is on there we
did it we finally finished Boston
Dynamics - it's time to hit render this
is the last shot and we're done
it's been a heavy week which is why we
got a heavy beer this is a keg of home
brewed beer
dark malt or is that a dark study dark
if you're watching this just trust us
we're having a great time go over and
watch the actual video it's finished
it's on the quarter channel there's
links everywhere go check it out we'll
be here when you come back don't worry
okay all these we put so much work into
this video it's like months just take
five minutes sit down put on some
headphones enjoy Sam sound design enjoy
all of our hard VFX work you want to see
a video on making beer subscribe this is
really good it's like not too bitter or
hobbies
it's like Guinness without the water in
this